>> Hi, I'm David Baumert,
and I'm a member of
the Microsoft Strategic
Prototyping team.
We're in part of the API
and Research Division.
Today, we brought some
receptionist assistant robots.
We plan to deploy these
later on in building
99 to help receptionists be
able to stay at their post,
yet still do more
within the building,
and then also be able to
interact with
a wider range of people.
This particular robot is going to
help us retrieve items
from inside the building,
and then deliver them to people.
It's using a combination
of local processing,
and cloud processing to do
image recognition
and motion planning.
The result here, is that
very different from
an industrial setting where
everything is repeated.
This robot is able to figure out
the situation at the time,
and is actually able to
retrieve the beverage from
the inside of the refrigerator.
So over here, there's a bit
of review of what's going on.
Part of the process
for figuring out
how to move is to
run simulations.
When a simulation is found
that actually works
as a solution here,
then that data is provided to
the robot that commands
the joints into
the specific sequences needed
to actually grab the beverage.
So, one thing we can see
here as we're waiting,
some of the computing costs of
these various tasks can
effect the quality of
this scenario in different ways.
So, what we're very
interested to know is,
what makes sense to run
here locally and what
makes sense to actually
ship up to the cloud?
So, if those kinds
of optimizations of
where the code is
actually running,
potentially can speed
up this scenario.
But as you can see
it's able to effectively
get the task completed.
So, we think this is one step
along a story that's going to
continue about
a beautiful relationship
between humans and robots.